d'animation d'émoticônes et même vos
personnalités préférées du monde des
échecs des émoticônes et les emojis
disparaîtront au bout de quelques
secondes en revanche les notations de
coûts et les animations spéciales telles
que sur l'échiquier jusqu'à ce qu'elles
soient effacées ce père il suffit de
cliquer avec le bouton gauche de la
souris pour des mouches notifications
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau live Fabienne salut à tous enfin
bon on nous voit en double
c'est parfait c'est parfait les parties
donc qui se lancent immédiatement donc
pour ces cars de finale Fab
et bien on va suivre le car entre Jordan
jour à neuf sur neuf donc très
impressionnant et ventes forest donc
c'est qualifié c'est un beau petit carte
finale première partie donc bon de
Forest avec les Blancs
on va revenir un dessus E4 A6 D4 E6
cavalier F3 D5 cavalier C3 donc Fab ça
c'est une ouverture qui a pu être jouée
en par le passé par le grand maître
français Christian Bauer exactement mais
[Musique]
en fait il avait une idée derrière la
tête quand il jouait à 6 alors c'était
plus sur D4 d'ailleurs
vous allez me dire 4 à 6 D4 ou des 4
racistes 4 ce sera la même position
certes mais l'idée en fait c'était que
contre des joueurs de un des quatre
quand ils faisaient son coup à 6 soit il
jouait avec avec ces quatre il voulait
avoir des B5 qui pouvaient partir assez
vite donc peut-être pas beaucoup de
numéro 2 mais en tout cas que vous
pouvez partir ou quand je joue avec C5
D5 V5 c'est une sorte de bengo améliorer
je sais pas pourquoi alors attends
on va juste faire une
sinon je vais en manger un deuxième
c'est pas très grave on verra ouais donc
c'était son idée et sur D4 racistes E4
du coup il voulait jouer une française
alors version inférieure mais
[Musique]
contre un joueur qui joue des 4 premiers
coups qui fait pas 4 il y a pas mal de
gens dans ce cas-là donc les prendre un
autre terrain là de commencer par E4
assis ouais ça c'est plus rare donc il y
a tonimails là dessus mais c'est ouais
c'est pas trop bon normalement
je vais juste je remets juste bien le
chat pour qu'on ait bientôt en tout cas
E4 il a joué à 6 D4 6 KF3 D5 et C3 fou
B4 E5
food et 7 fous des deux fous prends ces
trois fous prends ces trois fous B5 donc
c'est quand même quoi qu'il en soit une
Française améliorée pour pour vendre
forest oui exactement mais du coup voilà
bah Magnus il a quand même deux trois
petites idées assis il la justifié ils
vont être sont fondés 5 et changer son
son mauvais fou
et
bon à ce que je joue Jordan si c'est H4
pour prendre de l'espace aller droit et
pour essayer de faire H4 H5 H6 affaiblir
les cases noires adverse maintenant
qu'il y a plus que lui qui a un fou de
cette couleur
[Musique]
ça paraît descend comme idée tu peux
sûrement jouer d'autres choses peut-être
des fous B4 des coups comme ça aussi
on va voir un Fab le coup le coup qui va
décider
je voudrais juste mettre le la qualité
de l'air Fab et
c'est chez Magnus alors on achève forest
on lâche avant de forêt donc on voit
qu'il a une bonne qualité d'air mais la
température en cet été Fab est un peu
élevé donc ça m'amène à la question
est-ce que c'est donc c'est une
information qui peut avoir qui fait
chaud grâce à son petit boîtier rings
est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui peut
être important de savoir qui fait chaud
pour pour mieux jouer ce que la chaleur
donc peut avoir un un impact est-ce que
ça fait trop chaud ça peut être
difficile de jouer finalement ça dépend
des coureurs je pense
certains vont être plus à l'aise sous la
pluie
chaleur mais clairement il faut bien
penser à s'hydrater et
peut-être un petit coup de ventilo de
clim de enfin une petite douche entre
les parties d'eau froide la rapidos pour
se mettre les idées en place
mais pas le reste je sais pas mais a
priori le micro
je suis pas fait pour ce micro quoi
il y a une bonne position ouais
mais étonnamment j'ai l'impression que
je l'ai déjà eu ce micro donc sinon je
vais sur l'autre
on va faire un changement de siège
qui va peut-être être bénéfique pour
femme
alors qui a mis Charles qui qui est avec
nous
en ce début de partie mais ça va bien se
passer ne t'inquiète pas Fab
ça va très bien se passer
donc il y a eu dame cette alors est-ce
que c'est un peu mieux ou pas ouais ça a
l'air femme on va on va se mettre comme
ça ça va être notre setup
ça me set jouer ok
bon en tout cas l'ouverture il la joue
assez vite pour un truc qui existe pas
et ça va pas si mal pour ma Magnus enfin
dans l'autre
mais j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont les
biens tirer finalement le joueur
norvégien peut-être c'est dû à cette
chaleur qui gêne peut-être avec les
Blancs exactement c'est un petit peu de
sueur de son côté petite perle devant
les yeux qui te fait voir flou
il est il est perd les Fab il est perd
les
on voit la bâtard de Magnus il a mis
l'avatar au siècle le Père Noël lutte
contre la chaleur comme il peut le
norvégien
et ouais donc on a pas son ring à Magny
alors pas pour le moment mais on imagine
hein qui fait moins chaud chez lui
mais en norvégien et oui c'est quand
même des des informations importantes
parce que tu pourrais
tu peux parfois penser à ça va il fait
pas trop chaud et finalement tu es
affecté
donc c'est 5 on voit qu'il va régler
tous les problèmes de la française
Magnus
ah ouais bah il peut perroquet quand il
veut pourquoi pas maintenant d'ailleurs
et son roi va être en sécurité et il a
déjà pris la colonne C pour sa tour
l'aéroportionne le cavalier donc vers la
caisse C6 donc il sera beaucoup plus
actif qu'en 17 puisqu'il va pouvoir
attaquer le pion des 4 et où sauter en
B4 en A5
donc en fait il a des belles cases et
voilà et puis bah le fait de par OK
c'est vrai que c'est les dames s'échange
il peut aussi mettre le rang de 17 où on
le sait par la suite
ah il a déjà l'avantage dans ce quart de
finale alors après quoi qu'il en soit
c'est un double élimination un tournant
en deux éliminations donc même si on ne
forest on a perdre ce match aujourd'hui
contre Magnus Carlson il continuerait
quand même il jouerait encore demain
exactement il faut perdre deux fois pour
être éliminé
et on joue des matchs en quatre parties
tant qu'on est dans le dans le principal
dans le tableau principal et lorsqu'on
rejoint le tableau des perdants les
losers le loser bracket Fab à ce moment
là on
enjo plus que deux
alors bien sûr s'il y a un partout il y
a le fameux Armageddon à enchères donc
qui est propre à ce tournoi
et voilà mais effectivement ça évite
éventuellement
bon une inhumation surprise mais moi je
sais pas trop quoi en penser de cette
double élimination je sais pas vous si
vous aimez bien le format vous préfériez
un tableau plus sec
alors là c'est pas sec c'est bien
ouais c'est plus en sauce bien sûr mais
tu sais un peu la sauce ouais
alors en réalité on devrait la voir mais
mais mais j'arrive pas vraiment à
aller voir en fait j'ai pas des caméras
intéressantes
de manière assez étonnante j'ai accès à
des caméras bizarres par derrière ouais
je sais pas
j'ai pas l'impression
ouais on regarde sur regarder vers la
droite mais j'ai pas l'impression de
trouver des caméras maintenant ouais non
ça donne l'impression que non
donc là elle change l'échange des dames
ouais mais qui va en tout cas plus ou
moins favorisé Magnus on va dire qui va
vraiment plus rien craindre dans sa
position après est-ce que ça sera assez
pour gagner c'est une autre histoire
mais en tout cas il aura une position
sans aucun problème
parce qu'en fait le problème pour les
blancs c'est que là les normes laisse
faire dames prendre le pion des quatre
donc il faut soit faire tourner un pour
clouer soit soit échanger soi-même mais
dans tous les cas c'est des coûts on va
dire juste pour défendre qui crée pas de
menace et les Noirs eux bon bah je
change les dames ils peuvent attaquer le
pion des 4 qui en fait est toujours le
cœur quand la française de la chaîne de
pions des blancs donc il faut toujours
surveiller et en plus à cause de ce cas
4 donc il y a des cases d'entrée avec le
kite qui pourrait être en B4 de façon
éternelle ou en A5 pour venir en B3 en
C4 par la suite donc en fait ça sera au
choix des noirs
et les blancs j'ai pas de d'idées
similaire quoi donc c'est
voilà ils vont subir un peu après bon
voilà il y a pas 12000 faiblesses dans
la position non plus donc ça doit aller
mais
ça doit passer
on va voir en tout cas la partie est en
cours
8 minutes chez ventes 12 chez Carlson on
va suivre cette partie et on voit que
vent de forêt se réussit pas à régler
ses problèmes de chaleur qui vont
peut-être le
le faire suer en tout au long de cette
journée Fab et il semble pas avoir la
solution retrouver une température plus
décente et on voit le rouge qui qui fait
mal c'est tout rouge c'est pas bon ce
serait jaune encore ça serait pas simple
mais ouais
température est trop élevée et qu'est-ce
qui se passe en chez karwana on va voir
alors
[Musique]
il fait un peu chaud aussi quand même
c'est pas terrible en fait c'est mieux
je vends de Forest au final ouais il y a
pas ce problème de de qualité d'air là
au dessus
CO2 qui est mieux chez vent de Forest
vers quelle idée ça va chez Cabana mais
pas mieux mais bon moi humilier des
moins choquant quand même
deux degré de moins c'est quand même
dommage ils ont accès au boîtier sing
mais j'arrive pas à régler pour autant
le problème pour autant et là c'est un
peu bête parce que la température c'est
quand même comment régler un problème de
température c'est un peu la question
qu'on se pose si il a pas la clim
je sais pas des glaces sont partout des
ventilos
faire un tour dans le frigo je sais pas
la forêt brûle on nous dit dans le chat
c'est un petit peu ça il est en train de
subir et c'est
Camille une mauvaise partie qui joue et
c'est peut-être pas étranger
en tout cas
j'ai envie de dire quasiment une erreur
de débutant Fabien pour se taire
c'est à 5 et c'est 5
par la suite
bon il va peut-être pas le laisser faire
tout ça et dire même avec à 5 on va
encore défendre des quatre mais voilà
s'il fait assez incroyable 3 3
ce sera un bel enchaînante cool ça va
bien
on te dit vas-y joue quatre coups
d'affilée ça serait cela
ce serait pas gagnant pour autant non
pourquoi pas
c'est vrai que c'est pas une idée bête
ça va doubler de part et d'autre ça
devrait faire une petite nulle assez
assez sympathique quand même une très
très belle partie Fabien
bah oui c'est pas passé grand chose mais
je trouve ça pour le match un peu
inquiétant pour pour rendre forest dans
le sens où si Magnus peut même se
permettre de jouer E4 à 6 avoir 0
problème
qu'est-ce que ça va être si il joue
un vrai truc
c'est une bonne question Fab alors que
là l'ordinateur je crois qu'il peut y
avoir un problème à un moment donné sur
cavalier c'est 5 tu auras pas les B4
aura peut-être que Magnus est en train
de jouer quelques coups à côté c'est
dommage qu'on n'est pas accès à son
heure est-ce que est-ce que finalement
il y aurait pas des problèmes aussi de
son côté
on va essayer de trouver l'accès
mesdames et messieurs pour vous donner
plus
d'informations sur le sujet
parce que même cavaler ces cinq qui
allait prendre des cartes quand même à
chaque fois
et sur quoi qu'il est pas toujours
revenir en C5
en tout cas très belle partie tournoi
qui commence fort Fabien
ah voilà oui avec quand même un certain
enjeu je pense qu'on peut on peut aller
voir rapidement
le trophée du tournoi s'en en reparlera
un petit peu plus tard c'est un trophée
qui est créé de toute pièce de toute
pièce Fabien il y a un site dédié mais
il manque quelques informations pour
être pour être précis mais quand même on
le voit déjà
donc ici on a le trophée le format on
vous en a parlé
maintenant
donc on est en 8e de finale
on a eu le
cheskybug Master's merci on est sur le
MKS très beau site Fabien chef
puisque c'est un site qui te permet
finalement de télécharger et télécharger
toutes les parties que tu as joué en
ligne notamment
ou autre tu pourrais même jouer sur le
litchess ou autre site il est téléchargé
un diagnostic
de ce que tu as fait de ce que tu as
fait tu es pour un fort et point faible
et il te dit quoi travailler Fabien
genre fais de la tactique
[Musique]
il te fait
et il te fait retravailler sur les
exercices que tu as que tu aurais raté
[Musique]
les reprendrai pour te créer un profil
et donc ouais le
calendrier lundi donc les quarts de
finale des gagnants mardi on va avoir
quand même des demi des gagnants demi
des perdants des consolantes bon ça va
être
partout jusqu'à mercredi avec les
finales des gagnants les consolants des
perdants jeudi il y aura que les
perdants et vendredi la Grande est
magnifique finale qui pourra jouer en 4
ou en six parties donc ça c'est vraiment
le le point phare du tournoi qui serait
évidemment vendredi 14 juillet on espère
avoir un français pour cette fête
nationale mais il y en a pas là sur le
tableau donc sera pas possible
on peut voir le tableau d'ailleurs vu
qu'on en parlait avec
ça
topsof à rognan itouris Zaga et vente
forest Carlsen avec une superbe partie
passante tableau et peut-être un Carl
scène car wanna
qui va rapidement arriver et les joueurs
vous pouvez les voir avec les photos en
grand plan on va Magnus Carlson le
sourire du norvégien heureux de sa
partie qui est en train de pas trop mal
se passer contre sarouana
à l'affût il a l'air déterminé 30 ans en
2796 l'avenir fait doser le regard un
petit peu fuyant
28 ans 20079
et le rapide sur chaise comme bien
évidemment il y a le chat
très concentré
s celui qu'on appelle aussi le charisme
la forêt
qui est au prix justement Fab avec
Magnus Carlsen
enfin indépendante en tout cas et
alors bon au moins Jordan il a tenté un
truc il a pas liquider les tours sur la
colonne c'est il a pris du pion
donc c'est un petit peu modifié la
structure de pion
sûrement ça va pas forcément modifier
l'issue de la partie mais au moins se
permettre de continuer à jouer et
peut-être tenter quelque chose un jour
avec une percée à 5 ou peut-être C4
reprendre avec le roi s'avançant adverse
peut-être un dessin après je sais pas
donc il prétend au moins faire quelque
chose et pourquoi pas ça montre qu'il
n'est pas non plus effrayé de jouer
contre Magnus et qui saute pas sur la
nul dès qu'elle est là quoi il y a
peut-être quelques velléités
offensive
G4 B5
mais mon petit à petit ça pourrait
devenir mieux
après il a un bel avantage à la pendule
quand même
ça peut jouer
il faut être précis pour conclure ou
dans la finale ça joue sur des nuances
ça peut ça peut compter
on va voir on va laisser les joueurs
s'exprimer Fabien ceux qui ont la vérité
de la position
donc on va regarder un tranquillement
cette partie
alors regarde très bien
je pensais qu'il prendrait de la tour
peut-être pour se garder un pion passé
du pion pour
c'est inquiétude
forest réussi à faire baisser la
température de 4,5 degrés ça pourrait
devenir compliqué tout d'un coup
peut-être qu'il arrive à faire durer le
match il serait plus fort avec la
nocturne qui arriverait
un petit peu et là pour avoir un air
absolument parfait
neurones qui arbures à fond et là ça te
terminerai
inquiète pas pour Carlson
qui réfléchit maintenant et oui
il était trop facile à Magnus
il y a des Français dans d'autres disent
je crois qu'il y a un Français qui joue
c'est Laurent fraîchement en division 3
ouais
[Musique]
mais même la division 3 c'est pas c'est
pas c'est fort quoi
c'est qualifié en 3e division
très bien être en 3e division un jour je
peux même
et être en première division
et donc pas mal joué ce qui est ici 5
j'imagine qu'il aurait bien aimé pouvoir
jouer B4 se débarrasser de ce pion isolé
mais il y a le cavi qui viennent à 6 et
ça gagne quand même un pion donc tu as
pas forcément eu de le perdre comme ça
donc tu vas rester un petit moment
exception B un peu faible quand même
alors pas évident d'aller gagner mais
c'est quand même un truc à se surveiller
et puis il est blanc à tout le monde
peuvent te faire tourner décaler rentrer
donc c'est pas tout simple côté noir
c'est même compliqué
il a joué tour B6
voilà donc peut-être pour préparer B4
sans curiacis au final
juste pour attendre aussi enfin
après B4 en même temps le pion il reste
planter là
[Musique]
avoir un Fabien attends les couilles
sont pas mis un jour tout seul
Magnus
et Rodez 3
peut-être
joli bah il a
ouais il a bien réfléchi pour et là il y
a peut-être le bébé français du coup là
exactement qui a peut-être été raté un
parent de Forest qui commence à payer
ses efforts et la chaleur aussi
éreinter
il a raté hein
la roue tourne en train de tourner
il va quand même réussi ouais il va
filer le pion et il va essayer de
s'activer de l'autre côté avec la tour
ouais mais bon je sais pas si il va
tenir
ça peut suer
apparemment le rêve quoi
non non c'est difficile
c'est très difficile même
disons il a les pièces actives le
cavalier il est pas mal il tient ses
pions il va bloquer le pion passé
adverse il a un roi bien dans le jeu
il a avancé ses pions de l'autre côté
les normes pas très envie de faire je
plonger parce que sur Air France donne
le purge passé donc peut-être qu'il peut
maintenir un statu quo mais
voilà Magnus qui a quoi 5 minutes
d'avance à la pointe quasiment il peut
il peut tourner peut-être et
la roue tourne pour y tourner
la roue tourne pour tourner Fab
exactement
on va voir peut-être faire tour à 8 pour
essayer de passer par derrière mais tour
B8 sans la porte après on échange ou pas
les tours
il a fait roi des deux donc bon il veut
juste attendre
mais ok je sais pas si tu peux maintenir
un statut ici
j'en ai aucune idée
je n'en ai aucune idée
on tourne à 5 en tout cas il veut
échanger les tours donc soit il échange
soit il fait tomber 6
mais bon ça permet au roi de lancer
cette gagner un temps et à l'autre de
rentrer peut-être un deux donc il a
plutôt échangé
et reprendre ok quel est bien joué va
vergers
comme ça en fait
la nuit est peut-être tenue en partant
de Forest
mais parti un peu étrange en fait c'est
pas passé grand chose on a pu croire à
un moment mais bon c'est pris une petite
tactique et mais on s'en sort bien
belle partie
est-ce que tu sais si ça reprend direct
ça enchaîne ou ils font des petites
pauses et c'est genre une par heure ou
je sais pas non mais c'est pas une par
heure mais il y a des petites pauses
mais c'est la partie durée 15 minutes tu
aurais pas attendu 45 minutes déposez
quoi il y a des pausettes ouais qu'on
fera évidemment à nous aussi
pour récupérer
et rafraîchir également rafraîchir ouais
c'est c'est l'été partout
et essayer de voir avec ces micros qu'on
peut faire je suis pas sûr que je sais
pas si la qualité est bonne on va me
dire dans le chat
mais
les petites choses étranges avec
la partie qui se joue
mais la Magnus peut plus vraiment rien
tenter donc ça devrait s'échanger
ouais bah vu qu'il va perdre son pion là
je sais qu'il y a quand même un pion
passé pour les blancs son roi va être
obligé de rester à l'affût dans la zone
là-bas bon après les blancs prend pas
aller plus loin non plus mais
l'un dans l'autre
ça va être bloqué
le cadeau
la comédien
il y a plus de manières de
presser
de jouer donc maintenant il faut y aller
avant
ces choses faites
là il y a plus de il a pu avoir de jeu
ni d'un côté ni de l'autre égalité
matérielle il y a plus assez de pièces
sur l'échiquier
[Musique]
ouais les blancs en fait vont juste
bouger leur roi pour attendre il vaut
mieux si vous jouez cavaler le renard en
H6 ils ont pas envie donc ils sont
contents de leur petite barrière là avec
les cavaliers donc tout ça ça va rester
en place et
pendant ce temps il attend quoi
avec le roi non même pas mais j'ai trois
maintenant peut-être
avec
logique
on parle souvent de cette chaleur
accablante chez vent de Forest parce que
là en fait il a pas eu l'air d'avoir vu
l'idée en fait
du coup
je repars
aussi peu de temps
une canicule
toujours
il est pas bien en tout cas plus ça peut
te faire suer tu peux déraper que ta
souris faire des mains au slip
croisé si sûrement 3 pour défendre le
pion Fiat c'est fait
maintenant sur F5 qui peut faire qu'avec
la renvoyer le roi chez lui donc pour
l'instant c'est pas un problème mais ça
pourrait le devenir un jour
il réfléchit en tout cas
ouais mais il doit essayer de voir s'il
a pas un petit piège qui traîne c'est un
moment de faire
des cadres donner le pion pour faire
wave 5 fois F4
ouais il a le temps de mettre une petite
peau de banane quoi
qui doit être en train de
chercher de faire de chercher ouais
OK
par là-bas
c'est quand même ouais c'est bien joué
de sa part si vous êtes deux j'imagine
qu'il y a ici 4 pour déloger le cavalu
au 3 et avoir Roy F5 et là il empêche le
renard de venir dans son camp donc pour
l'instant il tient le choc
après faut avoir si le pion D peut
avancer un jour
alors pas encore
B4 en disant bon bah le pion est perdu
mais c'est vrai que Descartes qui est
ici ok B3
ça peut quand même se regarder
ça a l'air dangereux
parce que des quatre F5 sinon
le liquide encore un pion
c'est dangereux en tout cas mais ouais
enfin
c'est chiant quand un second quoi
d'avoir un pion passé qui t'arrive
dessus et c'est quel jeu alors faut
juste pas échanger ça c'est clair
logique bloque le pion passé adverse
peut-être qu'il y a des quatre rouages 4
pour rien faire H4 c'est fait
intéressant
en fait j'ai pas encore en tête le truc
qui veut lui planter mais il doit avoir
un setup très précis où il veut ce que
Jordan se trompe quoi pour pour lui
planter en fait j'arrive pas non plus
j'essaie de réfléchir mais je me dis tu
peux te prendre un roi F3 ouais F5 qui a
eu 7 matchs pas piqué des hannetons
faire attention quand même
ta 3G 4 à nouveau
qui va pas réussir à gagner mais ce sera
très très proche ça va pas être passé
loin de la correctionnel pour pour
Jordan non pour la suite du match
là quand tu fais une longue défense
comme ça cette
use un petit peu quoi
il va utiliser
et réfléchis en tout cas
Magnus encore mais il lui reste plus
beaucoup de temps
non le non plus peut-être il va juste
répéter non
attention il peut y avoir des ordres de
coude et finesse qui sait
refaire ranger 7 maintenant
il a pas envie
ok le fameux F5 est parti donc peut-être
liquider un pion aussi de la case F4
pour le roi si nécessaire
et maintenant le roi de Magnus qui
repart de l'autre côté
[Musique]
c'est mieux de rester comme ça
attention Jordan
[Musique]
revenir
il était trop C7 qui gagnait
il est complètement enfermé le frérot
bon bah écoute ça va être une corde au
final l'usure
pour ça que ça allait quand même tenir
côté jardin
pas tellement
attends il tente encore sur Roissy
une fermeture
du ventes qui s'encline avec les Blancs
directement une belle option pour
final
dans ce match dans ce quart finale
dans les autres parties
Fabienne a fait nul contre Zaga
et on a quoi d'autre
il a fait nul
et c'est quoi
on a vu la salle victoire sur la bonne
partie on va faire prendre une petite
respiration Fab et on revient et on
revient
pour la suite des événements à tout de
suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça reprend mesdames et messieurs
ça reprend et c'est une berlinoise je
choisis par un monde forest
donc la ligne un peu à la mode là
symétrique
est-ce que tu penses que Magnus va faire
une nulle rapide
je sais pas ce qu'il veut faire en fait
après nul c'est pas mal pour lui de
toute façon c'est lui qui a un point
d'avance dans le match maintenant donc
s'il y a plus que des nuls il a gagné
donc ça sera plutôt à son anniversaire
prendre des risques tôt ou tard
mais bon après c'était l'opportunité
d'enfoncer le clou bah tu enfonce et
puis il y a plus rien
peut-être l'intérêt qu'il a
donc je sais pas les va jouer il va
jouer pour jouer et puis il verra bien
c'est un peu cette ligne ou gagner un
pion des 4 mais se faire défoncer la
structure alcalier arrive donc il a pas
choisi ça il préfère la position
symétrique donc plus ou moins égal mais
les blancs vont être les premiers à
entrer en action sur la colonne 1 donc
il y a un léger plus
et voilà il s'est pas grand chose mais
Magnus est plus ou moins à l'aise dans
ces jeux de manœuvre ce qui va être
compliqué pour vendre forest c'est que
je vois qu'il a toujours pas réglé ces
problèmes de température
il reste bloqué à 27 degrés mais
peut-être qu'il va pas regarder le
boîtier qu'il a pensé à aller ses
ouvertures tout ça mais
que le boîtier donc
c'est quand même un peu bête
il le met pas à profit
que le problème soit absolument absolu
mais bon
[Musique]
de lieu de résidence
c'est complexe pour pour lui
c'est complexe
donc la 4 à 5 il bloque son avancé sur
Zelda il remet le fond des trois mais il
est plus actif qu'en F1 donc il regarde
un peu vers le roi adverse contre le des
cases il évite au foie de verse de
développer sur ton F5 et après qu'il y a
eu F3 bah il veut simplement peut-être
venir en E5 avec son cavalier par la
suite et j'ai 7 fois 6
sont des cours assez logique pour le
moment
même très logique
non
un truc sur kf5 mais je
plus ou moins envie si tu peux
pour déloger fous
et voilà donc comme je vois pas de
tactique je me dis que je vais peut-être
juste repartir avec une fois quelqu'un
F5 quand il rappelle le fou mais j'en
sais rien
il faut aussi en tout cas jouer
et peut-être un coup de dame pour
libérer la case 1 pour la tour
éventuellement
en tout cas comme un peu la partie
d'avance c'est pas une partie méga
animée des ondes tactiquement et
compagnie après s'empêche pas qu'il y a
des petites peaux de banane ici ou là
comme tout à l'heure on se souvient du
du B prend C3 là qui avait été bien
senti exactement en B5
bon H3 tranquillo ouais c'est pas la
partie la plus passionnante de
l'histoire des échecs pour le moment
mais bon
c'est quand même un peu mieux pour les
blancs et sans risque exactement
oh il est en mode gestion il y a pas de
problème comme on disait il peut faire
il peut faire trois nuits et gagner le
match et ce qui est ici pour les
demi-finales donc il y a pas de raison
de jouer comme un fou fou c'est c'est
jordanoise
donc
vis-à-vis avec la Dame Blanche donc à ce
moment-là ce qu'on peut faire avec les
Blancs pour nous aussi venir avec la
tour
voilà des deux c'est un coup facile
après d'autres encore plus fort
d'ailleurs mais
sans jouer simple même des deux ça
semble simple et pas trop mauvais
je dirais même assez bon
la prochaine avec les Noirs tu as gagné
le match quasiment pour minus donc
on pourrait avoir des échanges très
massifs très vite mais bon la partie
d'avant en fait ça semble être tellement
aller vers une lune sans problème et
qu'il a quand même fini par gagner et
que
en fait il est quand même capable de
nous gagner ça
le bougre
il en est capable
on va voir comment ça se passe là j'ai
l'impression que
ça va s'échanger massivement ça prend ce
chemin après bon est-ce que Magnus envie
d'avoir des velléités de commencer à
faire des choses d'envoyer un petit G4
il peut
adverse qui reste en G7 un peu bloqué le
fou un peu moins d'espace et Nord
doivent prendre en compte des G5 un jour
alors bon pour l'instant c'est pas trop
le projet mais faudra quand même
regarder à chaque fois on peut enlever
le cavalier faire F3 h4h5 ou enlever le
cavalier faire F4 F5 donc il y a des
projets éventuels
et aussi on se lance libérer la case
aussi pour se cavaler un moment
donc le fou a fait son travail en fait
il y a pas mis la tour passée comme
c'est une pièce longue portée
enrichissement C8 il contrôle pas plus
de cases donc autant le mettre là-bas il
garde cette diagonale il défendue en V7
et il permet la tour de s'activer
deux trois petits bricoles en même temps
[Musique]
téléporté chez parram
dans une autre division lui aussi n'est
pas en Ligue 1
[Musique]
s'est retrouvé avec le match de l'autre
côté pour pouvoir les caméras du match
du Rabahi j'ai l'impression
par un ou alors en tout cas ou si je
pense ensemble on pourra voir la caméra
de parram
voilà que durable
peu importe c'est pas non plus
non
énormément
sur le site internet moi
plus les émotions c'est mieux filmer là
c'est de la webcam il y aura peut-être
des équipes techniques
ça jouerait en hybride ou quoi ce serait
une autre histoire mais évidemment un
hybride
bon si il échange votre nul sans
histoire il peut aussi garder les dames
et reculer d'une case en E3 pourquoi pas
ça restera rien de spécial mais au moins
il y a toujours les dames sur
l'échiquier
[Musique]
bah il se passe pas grand chose désolé
enfin désolé bravo c'est comme ça hein
on commande ce qu'on va mais oui quand
il y a
quand même un match de foot il y a 0-0
pas d'occasion pas de bon bah
c'est comme ça
ouais c'est comme c'est
ils disent
je sais que quand tu es fans tu peux
supporter ça regardez les images de
synthé complètement nul ça va pas être
des synthé qui joue jamais j'aurais
regardé ça mais là bon j'étais devant
quand même j'espère quoi donc là il y a
des supporters de Jordan avec les Noirs
ils doivent essayer d'espérer un
mystiques quelque chose laisse faire de
Magnus pour voir ce qualifier donc c'est
c'est un voilà c'est autre chose c'est
pas que là pour la qualité du jeu tu es
là aussi en tant que supporter
bon nous nous
on est là en tant que observateur neutre
presque
et objectif toujours
l'objectivité tu sais c'est vraiment mon
point fort
ouais
bon moi tu lâches quand même
[Musique]
ou comment les échanger si jamais ils
les échangent
je sais pas s'il y a des possibilités
éventuellement de faire craquer
l'adversaire dans ce genre de position
donc très très symétrique mais ou non
qui a ses pions qui ont été poussés donc
si un moment tu fais un BK4 tu crées une
tension quand même le cavalier qui peut
toujours aller faire un petit tour par
là-bas donc
il peut aussi la jouer long terme mais
[Musique]
un bon jeu des Noirs normalement c'est
ça tient bien quoi
on va voir
Roger donc un petit coup comme ça
prépare la finale active un petit peu le
roi
pourquoi pas bon j'imagine que Jordan va
échanger les dames ces choses faites
vous reprend
vous êtes il va vouloir échanger
maintenant les fous ou repasser le
cavalier il verra
ce qui va les passif moment il est 8
ok oui heureusement qu'il est là
alors j'ai cinq jouets
peut-être qui veut changer son s'il
vient là se donner la case je sais pas
trop il a des
[Musique]
pour le moment
est fuite jouer donc il se replace vers
le centre
mais au final ouais en fait m'amuse je
veux pas d'une petite nul
sans manger quoi il veut un peu
l'embêter ça a très bien marché dans la
partie précédente à vrai dire donc
pourquoi pas il y a pas un moment de
risque donc il sait qu'il joue plutôt
mieux genre de position donc il va il va
tourner
donc là le roi qui est revenu au centre
de chier c'est important aussi qui
défendent ce fou est-ce que jusqu'à
présent
important que le cahier ne bouge pas
parce que si on a bougé il y aurait eu
qu'elle prend G6 comme comme petite
tactique à la fois attaquer le fou et le
protéger vers l'arrière donc sur un coup
comme kg 7 pour venir là il y a eu des
problèmes
maintenant ça peut devenir un projet des
Noirs devenir rj7 à nous avec le
cavalier pour peut-être échanger sous ou
peut-être pour venir ici avec le
cavalier enfin avoir
[Musique]
en tout cas le roi voilà de toute façon
il est mieux placé naturellement et en
plus là il a raison concrète pour sa
présence
bien joué
malheureusement pas grand chose à dire
les coups vont arriver
alors 5 jouets OK
donc oui évidemment c'est une horreur
donc on va se ni touche pas et il pose
une question est-ce que tu veux prendre
ce que tu veux pousser nous pensons que
peut-être il voulait pousser pour
ensuite mettre le cavaliers là qui est
plus ta défense avec H5
alors il y a des comme on dit il y a des
bruits alors c'est des bruits de zoom
juste pour dire pour les gens qui se
demandent ouais qui arrive mais
censé nous envoyer vers vers une envers
un endroit où nous envoie pas donc bon
écoute c'est pas grave on va peut-être
finir par le fermer tant pis
non plus c'est ça c'est pas des bruits
qui dérangent quoi
ça fait une petite animation
donc faut bien garder cette diagonale
parce qu'il y a aussi l'option que dans
la ligne de mire du cavalier
non mais bon projet de faire ça quoi
mais même si je te fais prendre 5 fois
F5
je suis pas trop inquiet pour les Noirs
5 et j'aurais le lien avec les noirs
complexe
exactement disons le chat c'est
exactement ça
en fait peut-être un peu trop dans cette
partie
bon pour l'instant il a pas dépassé les
bornes mais peut-être maintenant faut
pas faire plus
F4 le projet des blancs ça serait
d'espérer bon je vais faire un mauvais
exprès d'avoir un truc comme ça qui
arrive et qu'en cas de prise faut
prendre on a une pression là-bas et que
si le caille bougeait peut-être des
sacrifices possibles pour faire un pion
passé mais il y aura pas forcément
scénario là puisque le fou peut venir se
récharger donc soit on échange d'abord
ici peut-être pour jouer contre fou
pourquoi pas dès maintenant parce que
même si on double les pions toute façon
il est pas vraiment attaquable le roi
n'a pas de passage et donc le Nord
pourrait prendre le Caval est là ou là
et tout va bien et celui-là on verra
qu'il est vraiment en muré derrière ses
propres options donc même si il est là
qui semblait peut-être idée de Magnus à
pas l'air
trop jouable après s'il fait vraiment
pas grand chose de mal il n'a pas
vraiment dépassé les bornes
effectivement
c'est pas pas une très belle partie je
dirais non mais bon
en fait
après il sort du grand chasso aussi un
Magnus qu'il a brillamment gagné
il a d'ailleurs peut-être voyagé je sais
pas moi d'où il joue aussi dans Croatie
encore si dans le coin s'il est rentré
chez lui en Norvège
parce que là il est vraiment pas bien
de si peut-être un jour
en tout cas B4 jouer
bon la partie qui commence un petit peu
à ça y est
ok oui
c'est animé
sans réfléchit en tout cas
prise
mais alors le problème c'est que tu peux
pas téléporter ton roi jusqu'à la case
G6 non tu aimerais bien mais il y a pas
de passage il fait F4 pour troquer
celui-là quand je suis là
de cavalier voilà
après faut prendre
et chaque aura
on aurait voilà c'est bien le cavalier
donc peut-être Roger 4 sûrement
d'ailleurs pour laisser l'autre venir
trouver de s'activer
vous faudra regarder ce qui se passe
parce que le Cavalier Blanc aurait cette
case sympa peut-être pour la suite
en tout cas on y va à droite dedans F4
jouer alors à moins qu'il veut jouer qui
a les points il faut prendre mais moi je
serais allé sur la finale de cavalier
plutôt les deux sont jouables
je l'ai pas envisagé de base mais je
viens de voir que c'était possible
F4 et essayer de mettre le four en D2 ou
en C1
c'est lui qui en avance dans cette
partie
il a 4 minutes de d'avance non il rentre
dans
des cavaliers tu vas pas laisser de
grands souvenirs dans la partie
précédente
on va voir ici donc trois G4 attaques le
cavalier
après il peut pas faire de pion passé
avec B5 à 5
difficile à Fabien
on a l'impression que ce roi est en
train de monter à la volée il va pas
falloir mettre la balle dans le filet
ça ça peut être ça peut être la
difficulté en tout cas c'est une balle
de break là pour pour minus quoi qu'il
en soit parce que de 0 il ferait
vraiment l'écart mais attention de pas
se faire contrer
on va voir comment se passe le service
c'est important d'avoir une grosse
première balle
des épines dans le pied quoi ça peut
tomber des épines dans le pied ouais
exactement
relativement important
parfois ça se joue pas grand-chose
des millimètres même
avoir si vous cavalue
pour être un moment décisif déjà dans ce
mini match un deuxième
il fait cavaluer 4
voilà l'ordinateur adore les blancs
après cavaliers des trois
qui est joué instantanément ça fait mal
ça fait mal mais en fait en plus ce qui
est des trois désastons c'est logique
parce que ça défend à la fois le pion F2
et en plus ça vise un peu cette casse C5
ok il serait bien simplement bien ancré
dans le camp adverse attaque la
faiblesse en B7 donc
[Musique]
il se place pas mal
le problème en fait quand il va venir
ici donc pour aller changer mais les
blancs peuvent reprendre mais de toute
façon ça leur gagne des coups parce
qu'ils ont un coup d'attente deux coups
d'attente trois coups d'attente enfin
pour Renoir qui
se passe ici quand il y a la guerre des
oppositions
ça pourrait rapidement fermer ce match
oui en quête de 0 ça peut vite faire 3
ou 2 et demi et au revoir
après c'est comme ça ne vous en faites
pas toute façon on ira suivre les autres
les autres matchs alors pas pour la
troisième partie puisqu'on aime bien
comme si les matchs en entier et on
verra si ils vont devoir se réussit à
revenir et créer l'exploit mais après
s'il y a pas de quatrième partie on ira
voir
peut-être ce qui se passe dans cette
partie de tableau entre karwana et
history Zaga un très très beau match
aussi bien évidemment l'affiche de ces
quarts de finale
c'est ça
en tout cas on attend comme toujours les
coups
du coup c'est pas hyper content pour
Jordan encore que la partie précédente
ça allait très bien puis en un petit
coup comme si comme ça
devient plus simples donc ici trois
attaquer le pion il l'a poussé pour ne
pas te capturer
[Musique]
c'est vraiment une menace là il annule
le
B5 il va troquer B7 contre D4 ça paraît
risqué puisque le pion D est contrôlé
par le roi G4 en quelque sorte alors que
le plan va être difficile exactement
de toute façon c'est pas logique pour
Magnus d'y aller parce que de toute
façon on ne peut pas le protéger donc
autant faire qualic 5 et il prend des
cartes qui prend B7 et en plus les pions
a souvent ils sont difficiles à gérer
pour un cavalier même s'il y a pas de il
se fait choper par la banque
contrôle de 8 cases
que je suis en rosace voilà magnifique
et puis vers le bord moyen je suis là et
on contrôle plus que 4
et toutes les cases qui auraient au bord
autour on peut pas y aller et c'est le
problème pour rater spion en fait
celui-là qui cavalier ben il pourrait se
mettre devant ou ici ou là ou là enfin
plein de cases pour essayer de le
défendre alors que lui ça limite les
options donc là il vient en B5 pour
tenir la case à 7
mais
bon déjà le Cavalier Blanc un jour pour
intercepter tout ça propose un échange
aussi ça c'est un gros problème pour les
Noirs parce que finalement ce serait si
on pas terrible
donc
problématique un petit peu
et au-delà de ça le cavalier en C5
contrôlera la case
et si le roi passe en approchait on aura
tout loisir d'aller taper le pion G7
là-bas
ou les deux enfin
les pions
une faiblesse car elle va se calme non
pas du tout en ça se joue pas
peut-être qu'il a passé les parties de
votre chaise
[Musique]
donc à 6 ouais en fait
on peut attaquer un peu ce pion dans la
ici et en s'ouvrant un passage on peut
aussi jouer pour amener le roi au centre
et puis ramener le cavalier pour poser
un échange gagner encore de l'espace
donc c'est problématique pour les noirs
on sait une fois bon il fera pas grand
mal parce que le roi est dans le carré
ou lequel il peut revenir ici défendre
ce pion défendre cette case au passage
donc
[Musique]
ouais ça sourit encore une fois pour
pour Magnus ces petites finales simples
j'avais en fait j'ai failli dire qu'il y
avait pas le droit des huit
qui va conclure cette partie puisqu'en
plus ce cahier quand il arrive en F7 il
va pouvoir aller après en G5 et puis
bref il l'a pas vu
ça gagne aussi
oui j'ai pas envie d'un scénario j'en
sais rien au cahier des 8 Laura monte et
prend le roi monte il aide un peu ce
pion il a pu la flemme de quelques bon
après
il joue pour pour le contrôle d'ailleurs
qu'il D8 est encore possible
mais est-ce que des fois on peut prendre
ok oui
OK
il va mener très vite donc 2-0 dans ce
dans ce match break en poche
ok oui
Jordan qui essaie de trouver si par
miracle ou cavalier peut rebondir
défendre un peu tout mais bon les gens
sont trop forts
beaucoup trop fort
je vois un fou qu'il faudrait pour
arrêter de tels pion quoi il faut que je
vous les garder
te faire
garder le fou
regardez l'éléphant plutôt que le cheval
ok oui
[Musique]
là c'est terminé
facile enfin bon on va aller voir ce qui
se passe chez les autres matchs dans les
autres matchs
peut-être une petite nul aussi
Zaga donc là aussi ça va fermer le match
ça fait un zéro mais bon en train de
jouer
alors
écoute alors c'est quoi la pendule en
trois quatre minutes
c'est un gros match c'est vraiment le
plus serré sur le papier en fait on va
dire en tout cas
difficile de détacher un favori ce match
j'aime un peu mieux la position blanche
mais
c'est peut-être que visuel je suis pas
sûr qu'il y ait grand chose
à en tirer mais
ce match peut durer
deux très bons joueurs sont très dur à
battre simplement en fait
et
qui a été champion du monde rapide
dernier enfin il y a un an et demi et
qui a déjà gagné un de ces tournois ici
qui commence donc apparaître dans
l'élite et à faire des bons tournois
toujours plein de ressources donc plus
la cadence est courte plus ses qualités
peut-être de ressources peuvent
s'exprimer elle a des champignons de
rapides et pas de Blitz étonnamment
peut-être
mais bon dans toutes les cadences
rapidement
ils ont pas moins de 2e faiblesse mais
c'est un peu à 5 mais finalement on peut
pas faire beaucoup et tu as tout refait
une pierre deux coups
c'est ça bonne case en fait bien jouer
d'un match de parce que peut-être il va
créer un truc latent de peut-être prises
je me décale ou quoi
en fait je crois qu'il veut juste faire
F prend
ne rien faire ouais
bref on la dame défendrait
je crois qu'il y a vraiment rien à faire
dans celle-là
en train de jouer
blanc il a l'air bien
il n'a rien en plus mais les noirs sont
bien congestionnés
nulle part et donc la tour à 8 non plus
je pense les noms de te filer un pion
pour bouger mais il y aura pas le temps
vas-y va se prendre un cavalier sur la
case ou une dame ou un truc en tout cas
et puis ça bougera plus c'est un récital
en tout cas
c'est une partie sur moi intéressante à
regarder ou pour des coups ou du stage à
mettre de côté
et c'est un énième bijou dans ses
championne chaise sourd le M1 chess
rapide and chasse sponsor de ce tournoi
femme un excellent outil évidemment
tu es parti
analyser
comme ça ça te montre bien tes points
faibles ça télécharge les parties que tu
as joué notamment sur chetcom
c'est aussi fun c'est parti après sa
voix tout est hors tactiques tout est
pour un fort et point faible à quel
moment avec quel coup tu gagnes quelle
que tu perds ça te permet après de bien
travailler
et progresser
là c'est le fameux
c'était terrible et les blancs donc il
pourrait juste transférer cette tour de
l'autre côté par la suite tranquillement
mais sûrement et transporter numérique
d'une tour elle est loin
voilà le petit plan
facile
et même pas d'idée
ça fait un peu mal
[Musique]
dans le pétrin il fait des deux
tranquille focal là
elle joue quoi donc c'est la cata quoi
il fait toi F5 on va voir si les bonnes
fait c'est un coup qu'on a envie
de faire simplement pour se mettre à 3
cases bien défendre par là bien prendre
les cases par ici bon ça c'est déjà fait
mais voilà mais bon j'ai l'impression de
plein de coups sont bons
allez quasi tous pas fou B2 pas qu'il y
a des deux pour passer pour une
fourchette ici
à part ça ça doit aller pas dame 3 ah
oui dame B5
éventuels enfilade et puis il peut pas
sortir
je pense
on peut prendre
45 secondes de toute façon
je le prendrai celui-là
mais moi j'aurais pris aussi de toute
façon la tout gagne la position est trop
positive
mais en fait j'adore moi ces positions
[Musique]
comme tu parles de déco
mais ce qui fait GF
encore il y a tout qui gagne un tour H4
facile
[Musique]
ça changera rien mais
il y a des trucs de partout quoi dans
une telle position c'est normal des
choses marchent
bon allez partir sur une pause Fab je
pense qu'il va y avoir un abandon j'ai
du mal hein
ce que j'allais dire
[Musique]
ouais on sait même pas lui-même pourquoi
il joue
et ouais les sauts ça c'est gagné c'est
même plus à regarder
ceux qui jouent toujours
mais il a pas abandonné l'idée d'essayer
de jouer un petit peu
par contre
il y a pas de pas de casse d'entrée
donc là ça c'est nul
donc les vannes
et Carlsen et le match finalement le
plus serré sur le papier qui sera le
plus serré on va aller faire une petite
respiration Fabien on se retrouve très
vite
de la compétition à toutes les amis
[Musique]
les amis les joueurs ont repris un peu
un peu plus vite que prévu
et ouais Magnus Magnus qui en full troll
4 à 6 D4 c'est 6
un outil de retransposer une nouvelle
fois dans un genre de française un peu
bizarre ce match après c'est sur
Internet
alors attends voilà on a le bon visuel
il a fait il a fait 4 6 des 4 C6 cette
fois-ci
[Musique]
il a besoin que d'une pour se qualifier
pas juste assis ceci faut perdre un
temps excessif pour bien faire ses cinq
après
je sais pas pourquoi il troll le temps
avec un coup de retard et le pur et moi
je voulais prendre les noirs sans F7 et
les Blancs jouent et tiens on joue
encore
en fait les mecs vous l'épaule ou non
moi ça m'intéresse pas en fait donc
c'est peut-être ça en fait le même
délire
ouais pareil on verra la Coupe du Monde
ce sera pas la même
non non
[Musique]
partie classique
un peu plus de mal à montrer sa
domination d'un tournoi en fait par
contre dès que c'est plus rapide plus
Blitz là il
est toujours là quoi et donc on verra ce
coupe du monde justement ce serait
intéressant voir si il arrive à
reprendre l'ascendant partie classique
il va préparer exprès tu vas bien
travailler son répertoire ou s'il va un
peu plus de détente
et puis comment ça c'est un peu un
diesel s'il a pas d'accident au début
pareil c'est pas le mettre en confiance
parce que ça va le faire gagner une
partie puis une autre et qu'après des 3e
tour avec ça concerne un peu plus dur
qui sera qui sera déjà bien quoi ok oui
et je pense oui il aimerait bien gagner
cette coupe du monde c'est un des rares
tournois qui n'a jamais gagné en fait
et c'est un beau temps celui-là
c'est même pas le seul c'est possible
parce que il a déjà quand même joué
quelques fois enfin c'est pas comme s'il
avait joué une fois il a pas gagné bon
voilà c'est tout il y a eu plusieurs
participations
oh que oui
il a déjà quasiment égalisé en fait
salut sinon mais
ouais bon c'est pas le voir tout de
suite et puis voilà
c'est fou d'être autant plus fort que
les autres quand même
les autres sont pas nuls quoi ben non
enfin si du coup mais
c'est le seul hein
le 4 à 6 des 4 6 6
e
après 12 coups
ça me fera casse en fait
c'est pas normal en fait d'être aussi
fort c'est beau hein
après je suis sûr qu'il
le clip pose en fait il a dû y réfléchir
et
avoir qu'il s'était à peu près solide
c'est pas de l'impôt total sur les
joueurs
c'est impressionnant
en fait
donc E4 normal bon il fait à 6 déjà
c'est pas bon mais bon admettons des
quatre
bon juste à jamais vu ça quoi et enfin
peut-être des mecs à 200 hello quoi mais
après la partition un cours plus ou
moins normale et très vite
tu vois il est pas si mal et puis bah
avant de Forest un jour quasi 200700 en
face donc on va se permettre ça et être
déjà pas trop mal c'est
ça qui est incroyable donc B4 pas trop
attention parce que non aurait pu
prendre tu peux pas reprendre puisque la
tour sera en prise donc bref mais il
s'en fiche un peu d'être des roquets
parce qu'il a déjà mis le pion h donc la
tour pourra éventuellement coulisser par
ici je m'attends quand même un G4
[Musique]
j'arrive pas à comprendre mais je veux
une qui est quelque chose
mais je vois pas autre chose
mais bon c'est pas passion qui H6
[Musique]
en tout cas
pas mauvais parce que ça reste une
menace latente et tu verras de mettre
l'oranger de être contrôler donc c'est
pas un mauvais coup c'est juste j'ai
quatre approche direct qui avait l'air
juste bien
mais bon ok ça reste quand même toujours
plutôt bien pour les blancs cette
position
des deux parties d'avant et surtout pas
jouer de finale
bon après je sais pas si il va la gagner
encore on va voir on va dessert il est
abuse en tout cas
donc au centre quand le centre est si
fermé
bon il est même plus en sécurité ici que
s'il y a ok où on voit qu'il y a de la
spion ici et les pions peuvent arriver
mais bon weekend de l'espace pour les
blancs et les droits il y a plus de
pièces qu'avant il y a pas de finale
facile qui arrive
ouais c'est quand même trop ce qu'il a
fait
bon pour les échecs j'aimerais bien que
c'est parti mais bon quand c'est jamais
puni genre de truc j'y crois pas trop
mais
trop d'écart de niveau
school quoi j'aime pas trop le Kia 3 2
les trucs comme ça quoi
j'ai l'impression que ça ça
dévalue un peu les compétitions quoi
c'est surtout ça
en fait quand c'est un title je trouve
ça drôle c'est du Blitz bon là tu dis
quand même des gros groupes mais ouais
c'est vrai c'est compétitions qui
réussissent pas à s'imposer dans le
calendrier il y a pas de prestige quoi
non donc tu peux
là surtout il mène 2-0 quand même non
mais là bien sûr mais
aucun racisme ça va quoi et
c'est extraordinaire
un peu marre
oui c'est sûr
il finit à peine bam fort recommencer il
a aussi envie de s'amuser genre je sais
même pas tellement
je voulais dire
ouais bon de toute façon quand tu veux
le tirage tu te dis oui bon je vais pas
faire long feu après bon bah tu es là tu
es là tu joues
après mal au temps moi après ça à 8
minutes vous allez me dire mais ça peut
avoir son rôle évidemment on l'a vu
notamment dans la première partie où la
ligne finale nul il a finalement laissé
échapper
et donc là
ce qui est pas bête c'est à dire que ce
pion toute façon il est en plus mais il
est plus ou moins condamné elle est
tellement condamné qu'il est déjà pris
ce qui se passe donc c'est que ce pion
devient maintenant une faiblesse on peut
l'attaquer via des dames des trois
l'autre tour qui partirait peut-être
là-bas plus tard un jour attention à pas
donner celui-là pour l'instant
F7 peut être une cible aussi les
cavaluons des cases que ce soit
peut-être celle-là un moment ou l'autre
il peut venir virevolter faire des
choses et enfin il y a peut-être cette
case aussi à surveiller alors les nerfs
peuvent toujours contrôler par B6 mais à
ce moment-là c'est ce qui est
extrêmement bien défendu donc cette case
comment y aller F4 qui est D3 qui permet
de contrôler plein de choses et où faire
B4 côté blanc pour justement avoir
l'appui sur la case
en tout cas c'est avantage blanc clair
et net oui
ça réfléchit en tout cas
mais ouais c'est pas agréable pour le
coup même les finales sont pas trop
bonnes
c'était trop
on va voir on commence à continuer
même si je perds au pire je les blancs à
la prochaine non mais complètement
[Musique]
et encore plus tu te fais déconnecter
quoi
faut pas grand chose
c'est plus pour que le mater s'étale
peut-être dégager la tour
forest avec les Blancs
[Musique]
avec le fou et que la tour n'est plus
accès de case mais
ça reste poussif alors est-ce qu'il part
vers du cahier H5 qu'on vient de passer
de casse ça semble pas mal
Dame des deux très bien aussi comme
cours
de lier les tours
la dame garde par là donc elle est bien
jusqu'à les 100 balles peut venir
peut-être un F4 un peu attaquer espion
donc
ok ça fait des choses
ça fait de belles choses
qui revient au 7
bon en gros
spécial il essaie de tenir sa position
et des trois donc il recule maintenant
ça attaque le pion qui a pris de vrai
avancer j'imagine voilà c'est fait et il
a envie encore d'avancer je pense que tu
as pas une de le voir
à la tour qui pourrait maintenant venir
en G4 aussi un taper sur des 4 mais ça
je suis pas sûr parce qu'en fait pas
envie de lui c'est ça quoi
tout bétonner là-bas
et puis pourquoi pas partir un jour
c'est-à-dire qu'il est pas fixé en H5
là maintenant ouais ça c'est un coup
je sais pas trop comment on arrête en
fait
parce que le cavalier il est un peu tenu
à la défense de pion
la dame va revenir vers B6
qui est peut-être en train de prendre
l'avantage
ça ne suffisait pas en fait
c'est terrible
non
[Musique]
pas juste envie de quitter les échecs
mais déjà le tournoi pour commencer
en fait mais oui ça dégoûte
ça dégoûte un peu
maintenant il y a plus la faiblesse qui
avait tout à l'heure exception là donc
la tour elle ne fait ce qu'elle veut il
y a plus les tours tout bloqué il y a
plus lui qui avait les qui viennent
dominé et les mêmes problèmes que dans
les autres parties ce pion faible dans
cette structure
celui-là on sait pas trop mais bon ça
peut donner un tube le 5 jours et le roi
il est pas mal donc si on compare tout
en fait les noirs sont bien quoi ok oui
donc libère la dame de ces tâches
défensives maintenant peut-être pouvoir
prendre ce pion ou venir s'installer
quelque part
c'est terrible Fab
c'est la défonce
bon après c'est comme ça
et puis cette qualité de l'air qui a
toujours été réglé
ça on faisait trop pour un seul homme
façon en plus là quand même
un petit décalage peut-être
les barbels en fait même si annulent ça
permet le match donc
les barbels ne servent à rien
qui piquent au bout quoi
la dame peut un nouveau
s'engager vers la prison à 4
on espère que les prochains jours seront
plus palpitants ouais ça serait mieux ça
serait mieux
ce n'est que un quart de finale aussi
de l'imaginer
qui roule pas qui roule pas
de point bonus à l'arrivée rien pour le
verre
on peut penser à ça en fait
ouais ça existe pas beaucoup dans les
autres sports ce genre de ouais
c'est beau quand même qu'on arrive
toujours à dépasser
tu t'attends à rien mais je sais que
ça me bute
un petit coup de tour à 6 très bien
maintient la pression l'acteur qui peut
peut-être se mettre se décaler un moment
mais bon il le défendent il décale et la
dame arrive en a deux va faire même ça
clou ça permet d'arriver avec la tour
derrière
une pression sur
pour les échapper
au long cours
il y en avait gagné une non d'étapes
attaque de Jacky Lioran en tête du
peloton c'est toujours le combatifs
fleuves et puis bon il y avait les
montagnes non je parlais 10 minutes par
ascension mais ce matin
je sais pas non je crois pas je sais pas
une fois de chipolini qui avait
une demi-heure d'avance quoi
[Musique]
et faire prendre je sais même plus le
dérouler final mais ouais enfin derrière
il était pas tout seul en fait donc
je pense qu'il devait être content
d'aller choper des esprits
d'intermédiaires avant donc il était
parti en groupe devant et puis peloton
laissé filer il y avait un temps fou
d'avance mais
c'est dur c'est l'époque où il y avait
encore
de grands écarts en montagne en a moins
maintenant
c'est l'époque quoi IAM song Amstrong
pouvait reprendre
10 minutes à notre ami Sylvain Chavanel
cette étape
[Rires]
attaqué
[Musique]
je sais pas quel était les carreaux
sommets en fait ça dépend aussi les
braquer qui sont mis hein
ça se monte
dans ce truc là et il avait raison
je l'ai fait pas dur
mais c'est quoi du coup le plus dur pour
lui
je pense avant tout tourner pour lui
c'est
[Musique]
la mobylette
et en faisant un coup d'après mais quoi
qu'il en soit content d'échanger les
dames avant la petite finale avec le
pion passé
ranger 3 jouets
et faire ça mais bon dame de ça
ça fixe bien s'attaque la tête
je me qualifie
partie sans histoire
Wana dans la même partie de tableau
il a les blancs
il y a des blancs
j'aime bien sa position après je sais
pas ce qui peut vraiment faire j'aime
toujours bien voir un bon cavalier
contre le mauvais fou mais je crois que
c'est peut-être plus visuel qu'autre
chose parce que c'est 3 et pénible c'est
pas les tours sur une autre histoire
après manœuvré là on est un peu ligoté
donc
est-ce que tu penses que la forêt pleure
non
[Musique]
la case F5 bloquer cette colonne pour
pas se faire mater
I
qui résiste il prouve qu'il existe dans
ce tournoi plus que vent de Forest en
tout cas
mener un zéro pour le moment mais
vaillant
dans une quatrième partie
dans le match donc qui est pas mal mais
est-ce qu'il y a
Zaga et je sais pas pourquoi non est-ce
que cette chanson c'est
moi non mais
peut-être tu sens pas un petit peu en
capitaine
[Musique]
et tu sens qu'il revient dans le match
moi aussi je veux très vite
je sens vraiment dans cette vague de
capitaine abandonné quoi
un tout petit peu de ça non
mais un peu quand même quoi
bon c'est aussi pas passionnant
[Musique]
c'est en train de rentrer là
au prix d'un pion mais évidemment non
perdu un peu le contrôle que dans la
position
l'espace d'un instant
la tour qui se met derrière
sur la route donc ça perd pas de temps
c'est un trajet gratuit
et il contrôle les cases surtout
et la qualité de l'air comme un grand
maître 35 % de réduction du Racing wave
plus dans le Rapid chaise
et alors qu'on voit un carwana
il va falloir qu'il mette les barbe
niveau air
la fenêtre à la mi-temps du match
c'est avec ça qui peut faire la
différence
c'est jamais simple de finir
pas mal de CO2 chez lui
attention quand même
il met le plan à 6
plus de 10 secondes pour le joueur
venezueliens
en tout cas il joue pour l'équipe
d'Espagne
à la fourchette
il fait que maintenant attaque la tour
tout en bouge
pour baisser
la le pion à 7 maintenant je
suppose pour défendre son cavalier ainsi
il menace
à 8
de panique ce que j'aurais joué et
tomber 8 maintenant
et s'arrête en être fini des espoirs de
l'Espagne
va partir de la tresse ça finito la
qualification de Fabiano
[Musique]
elle capitale abandonnado
direct ok donc il gagne une pièce mais
il a essayé des puntos
on va voir on va voir ce qu'il en est il
revient il rattaque ce cavalier
la bête espagnole un peu trop tôt le
taureau espagnol
quoi
c'est un cheval mais s'il a pas s'il a
la dame automatique il va suer quoi pour
désactiver
[Rires]
il faut juste faire halte en fait
ce qui a été là à Paris la semaine
dernière enfin vendredi dernier on la
refait les autres non
ça va être là il a été sabotage et bon
bah du coup quel livre de
promotion dame alors il s'est passé quoi
à côté on va juste donner un résultat de
de Big Fish il a fait nul
avec les Blancs Evan se qualifier et
c'est toujours chaud
mais ça me fume
[Musique]
il le voit pas heureusement
le truc
c'est beau ce
promotion là qui a pas marché
mais franchement c'était beau
en fait
mais bon quand même assez souvent il
aurait dû le savoir
moi je savais pas
non mais il voulait faire
il a auto Queen
ça va gagner aussi pour Wesley
quand il a les blancs c'est pas fait il
y en a essayé
les bonnes avec les Blancs et western
avec les Blancs tous les deux qui ont
besoin de nulsif
la petite la petite pub
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier sur
perdu du monde au tournoi des candidats
en passant par le speechess ou les
titles
tuesday.com/aventure tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec il se déroulent
en présentiel ou en ligne vivez
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition au pronostiquant les
résultats tentez de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chains.com Flash
events aussi bien sur le site internet
ou sur nos applications iOS et Android
pour vivre votre passion comme nulle
part ailleurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et voilà Mesdames et nous sommes de
retour désolé pour l'attente vous savez
pas trop nous-même quand ça reprenait
mais c'est chose faite
ouais et donc obligation de gagner pour
Abdou sa torof avec avec les pièces
noires
c'est l'enjeu de cette partie donc
Wesley qui mène une victoire à zéro avec
deux parties nulles sinon
et on rappelle la calife déjà de Carlsen
et de Caravana dans le bas du tableau il
s'affront en demain les deux hommes le
champion norvégien face aux champions
américain
ça peut être que ce Carlson contre
contre l'Amérique en fait
ils ont pris une option
c'est beau
donc là c'est un peu comme une balle de
7 voir même de match pour rester
finalement
mais qui a le service à suivre ainsi 5
dans le tie-break
pour essayer
encore petit
peut-être tomber un B4 pour jouer
l'attaque de minorité
après une partie attention ouais c'est
qui peut être l'autre oui
et peut-être rejouer pour la nul
après il sait faire
un piège donc ça peut être une option
après bien réagir par A5 pour éviter que
B4 ne parte
obligatoire en même temps
il protège ce pion donc dans
l'éventualité où doit être plein de F3
ou 4 ça a du sens
aussi l'arrivée de cette tour ici qui
paraît viendrait appuyer ce genre de
choses
ok oui
toujours pas de F3 maintenant
le grand écart il tape à la loi et à la
dame l'autre assez souple pour tout ça
[Musique]
vers D3 un jour une belle case
exactement les cases des trois des six
pour les deux camps
jouer il revient il garde du contrôle
sur E4 F3 jouer donc tous les coups sont
assez logique en fait la dame peut venir
vers F2 par la suite une belle casse
permet de contrôler la casse des quatre
du G4 aussi on verra beaucoup de choses
peuvent arriver
ces quatre
qui arrive
normalement c'est on est encore dans le
rang d'observation dans cette partie
mais ouais les deux jours passent bien
leurs pièces et bon ça va un petit peu
s'animer par la suite en tout cas il y a
de l'enjeu il y a de l'argent
d'être fini
une longue route pour pour y aller mais
pareil si on perd
le deuxième disons cette offre
à deux 7 0 47 partout
mais après
dans les deux cas bien évidemment
donc la question peut-être que je bouge
la dame ou est-ce que je bouge je
comprends et je pousse
il y aura des pions comme ça qui
arriveraient bon
il a choisi l'option d'un F2
belle option
très belle option
ça réfléchit côté
tu donnerais quoi comme conseil
muscle ton jeu Wesley confiance en toi
et tout va bien quoi
conseil faps
pas trop bouger parce qu'il doit
soutenir ce qu'il y avait rien
mais effectivement c'est un coup qu'on
aimerait bien faire qui descend là qu'il
faut d'oublier les tours
mais c'est vrai que ce coup vient Saver
le pion B2 donc si on le reprend le
cahier n'a plus de défense donc il
faudra jouer ce coin terminé en disant
bah ouais mais moi aussi je te bouffe un
pion
et avoir ce genre de position là
ça donne
est-ce que on fait ça
bon moi j'aime pas trop mal les blancs
j'ai toujours bien voir le centre comme
ça mais
bon avoir capable mais ça pourrait être
ce qui se passe en tout cas en cas de
tourner en tout cas tu as pas envie de
perdre ce pion autre option c'est qui
est B3 mais je sais pas je sens pas ouf
le cavalier il peut se prendre des
donc avoir
complexe
mais qui défend tout
ouais
bref faut faire de pas se prendre
à 3 B4
qui était voilà peut-être le meilleur
coup en tout cas le coup qui donne le
plus envie à première vue
mais il faut avoir calculer
et avoir comment dire juger les
conséquences donc la fameuse position où
on aurait peut-être ces deux pions
centraux
et le cavalier par là on va voir
sans les crêpes là non
pas trop
ils sont brûlés
non
qualité de notre ère sûrement du coup
nos commentaires peuvent être moins bon
chez Carlos
mais elle est bon
27 degrés aussi
27 degrés c'est un peu partout quoi
du tournoi et des épreuves en général
donc c'est un boîtier qui calcule un peu
la qualité de ton air ou tu vois tu as
des métriques ici ou là et voilà donc
c'était chez Fabiano
ou en était voilà donc c'est parti avant
de regarder chez lui alors après tous
les gens ne l'ont pas installé ou non
pas connecté je ne sais pas faudra-t-il
qu'on a pas ce qui se passe chez Wesley
ou Nordir avec
c'est ce qu'on voulait faire avec les
Blancs donc maintenant qu'il peut qu'il
y a plus rien à défendre il est temps
et
très bien ça prend de l'espace au centre
donc probablement il va même continuer
par 5 et puis l'autre qui va arriver et
ça déferle
5 il parle logique le cavalier qui adore
choisir des cases vers l'arrière F4
ça va me masser
et en plus F4 des fois de coulisser de
faire des choses mais bon en fait si
vous avez ces trois pions comme ça c'est
juste la fin des haricots
[Musique]
c'est bien aussi
de gagner donc il peut risquer se
laisser attaquer pour espérer contrer et
que ça se trompe et puis si c'est pas le
cas il sera israéliminé sans être
éliminé on rappelle la spécificité de ce
tournoi ou
pour essayer de le battre et le défaire
lors de la grande finale du vendredi
14 juillet sera magnifique hein
spectacle exceptionnel qui nous attend
feu d'artifice tout
un beau trophée à gagner ouais on l'a vu
un peu plus tôt
des 4
attaque le cavalier qui a probablement
reculé
pour mieux sauter
ça recule et ça ça va sauter
il est parti en D1
relativement plus logique que B1
c'est 5 mais une pression centrale
trois
alors dis donne un avantage noir après 5
je suis de C4
ouais c'est qui a fait un peu n'importe
quoi dans les derniers
mais bon ça serait
c'est mérité il faut respecter le
la position parce que la position
demande certes le match ce nom de faire
nul mais bon si là tu dois faire F4 F5
faut faire quoi
parce que finalement les Noirs ils sont
pas mécontents dans lequel on décède
mais qui lui a aidé à faire ses cinq
pression sur spion
donc
[Musique]
il prend B2 donc il a la même idée on va
dire
après l'ordi c'est moi transcendant que
l'autre en tout cas il a l'idée
donc il faut le reprendre celui-là et il
va poursuivre par C4 faisant une
fourchette donc il va récupérer sa pièce
de moins ça lui donnera un pion passé
complexe
tu as sardache qui préfère avoir du 48
49% d'humidité le 46 genre 50 c'est déjà
trop tu as fait un spécialiste à mon
avis
ouais mais c'est peut-être ça Carlos ce
matin Moros peut-il bien commenter le
tournoi un autre humain que je ne
connaissais pas bien je passe toi tu
connais c'est un commentateur polonais
très pauvre
il a 43% du musée c'est donc c'est très
très peu
il fait 26 degrés quand même chaud et là
il y a du CO2 à foison dans sa pièce
peut-il ne serait-ce que commenter quoi
ouais je pense pas
allez on donne le bon exemple chez
Carlos plutôt
qualifié alors capable c'est top idéal
mais qui est quand même pas mal
air quality il fait plus chaud
maintenant il fait 29 il est parti il
faisait moins chaud lorsqu'il jouait
peut-être la clim qui était là
Jordan
est difficile de commenter sans
connaître exactement ce qu'il en a
exactement
alors il a repris du cavalier en B2 il y
a eu la fourchette et il avance
finalement le pion en F4
donc soit on s'attendait tout à l'heure
mais il y a une grosse différence par
rapport à ce qu'on voyait tout à l'heure
c'est là quand il va prendre on va de
reprendre qu'on a la tour qui est
attaquée et il aura le temps de venir
s'incruster avec son fou sur les gaz
blanches
alors que quelques coins sous son nom
est un plutôt comme ça sur F4 il va
encore se fondre donc on menaçait
vraiment ardemment le coup F5
donc c'est pas pareil donc il est prise
présentée
ce four en F5 donc qui empêche l'avancée
des pions et qui peut aussi faire des
choses peut-être cinq costaud ici un
jour et il contrôle la case B1 qui
pourra être importante plus tard puisque
c'est la case de promotion du pion passé
donc le four en fait est idéal sur cette
diagonale
en bonne santé
qui était pas très très bien au sortir
de l'ouverture mais tu es même très mal
mais ça tourne pas trop mal pour lui
alors bien sûr il y a rien de faim mais
en tout cas il y a des atouts maintenant
dans la position entre le pion passé le
fou pas mal les blancs plus grandes
initiative donc Wesley va être peut-être
dans son élément pour essayer de bloqué
le jeu mais il est obligation de gagner
pas ils sont éliminés de ce match
ils sont éliminés de du Winner Bracket
quoi
mais bon
logique
j'ai envie de dire enfin
il faut aller de l'avant quoi
sont pas mal quoi c'était pas si mal
dans l'échange
moi
aussi sans trop réfléchir en fait
ce serait déjà cliqué en fait
ce serait déjà cliqué
j'ai donné un pion mais on est déjà pas
obligé de le prendre dedans peut-être
même donner une qualité
parce que prise prise
ok la tour va venir s'incruster il y a
plus trop défendu il va se passer des
choses mais je me montre G4 full à Tours
si on prend je sais pas de quoi prendre
la dame a priori
tu vois j'aime bien oui il est parti
pour G4 là ce qui va donner la qualité
ce qui va juste bouger la dame suffit
voir l'évolution de l'ordi qui aime pas
du tout OK
ça
donc j'ai trois jouets il a juste
esquivé l'attaque
ce qui est très bien
et donc ce four reste ici un peu sous le
feu des pièces blanches donc il pourra
peut-être capturer plus tard
et F5 en tout cas ça reste un coup qu'on
aimerait bien faire
F5 jouet justement pour contrer le fait
qu'on le joue nous même
pas mal joué
en gros
soit peut-être prise en passant
soit un groupe G5 pour commencer un truc
tout bloqué comme il aime bien je pense
se présente et F5 et
logique
il y a le coup qu'on a pas du tout envie
de faire
ça j'espère que vous avez pas envie non
plus parce que vous fiez toutes les
cases à votre adversaire qui va
reprendre avec la dame
ça va exploser le pion F4 le four va
être vert très fort et toutes les cases
blanches sont très faibles donc ça on
n'aime pas trop a priori prise en
passant dame prend faire F5 justement
pour reprendre un contrôle avec l'option
Ouvrir la dame
ça
a l'air plus fort
mais tu as le trophée mces rapide ça
permet d'un billet VIP pour la finale du
Tour à Toronto en Canada et donc ça sera
en hybride la grande finale ouais ça va
être magnifique
en fait
maintenant
de ce côté
bon en tout cas
un mec qui doit pas être mécontent dans
le sens où il a un combat dans la partie
c'est pas fait sécher ou il se passe
rien
c'est pas genre les parties les
premières de Magnus contre entre
ça va peut-être que peut-être tu vas
bouffer à quatre pousse tes pions et tu
gagnes dans des coups
ça joue quoi c'est quand même sûrement
pas très bien
mais bon
on reste avec
[Musique]
certes tu as envie de faire d'autres
choses de l'autre côté quoi soit prendre
ok à toi
quand même
c'est bien d'être aussi fort et de faire
des coups c'est sûr qu'il sait que c'est
pas bon
il doit avoir sa perd pas
mais c'était mon conseil d'ailleurs que
je vais donner
ma tête quoi
il met pas les coups de griffe là c'est
plutôt le chat qui se met sur le dos un
peu
soumis quoi
un peu beaucoup
un peu beaucoup soumis il fait H3
bon après il blinde le jeu de toute
façon
c'est qu'il est très dur à battre et il
sait mettre des Marvel quoi
bah après ça c'est impressionnant à
l'inverse
maintenant
position compliquée pour
pour wesler mais il a l'air de tenir
ne pas trop laisser filer la pendule
c'est une bonne chose pour lui
ça devrait se qualifier
en tout cas c'est très bien maîtrisé
[Musique]
il prend tu parles une pièce puisque la
dame est attaquée attention sauf qu'il
veut dévier la dame ça pue attaquer par
la tour justement pour contre-attaquer
celle-là au passage et se caler restera
toujours en prise notez que lequel il
peut pas venir sur des cases ou des fois
dans la tour donc ça fait une double
attaque et surtout surtout ça lui donne
les deux pions assez liés de l'autre
côté quoi
mais ça sûrement
peut-être qu'une fois qu'il a joué c'est
la merde peut-être mais tu laisses pas
quoi
plus tard et tu as laissé ton initiative
à aller loin c'est bien fait non oui
alors non mvl ne jouez pas ce tournoi
les raisins non plus en fait il y a que
Jules qui a essayé de se qualifier je
crois de Laurent et Laurent
ils n'ont pas réussi
à moitié quoi
mais est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup de
joueurs alors qui jouent les califes
je pense
ça dépend des fois il a pris un 4 quoi
c'est incroyable il a même pas à jouer
le truc
là il te donne les deux pions passés
liés
cadeaux il va perdre
la partie dégueulasse quoi
[Musique]
il était bien il a pas voulu justement
jouer en disant nulle très bien et pas
puni par par le fait de pas jouer quoi
par quoi disent
bon maintenant il essaye de jouer il
fait un coup mais bon
ça peut ça peut tourner mais bon
à voir comment parce que l'attaque elle
me semble pas non plus si il faut 4 il
est tellement fort il est hyper fort on
monte ses diagonales qui défendent
partout il défend il attaque il est de
l'épiant avancés il y a les douches
là-bas
on aura le droit au premier Armageddon
ouais peut-être même deux je sais pas ce
que fait Levan en ce moment on peut
jeter un œil comme ça pour tenir au
courant
[Musique]
on avait eu une épreuve sur le choix de
la partie
donc
ok on confirmera si c'est vraiment
qualifié après mais revenons
ah ouais c'est
tout F2R
possible
après j'avais pas vu le contenu des
parties d'avant donc je sais pas comment
ça jouait mais en tout cas c'est dur
hein il y a une partie avec les noirs
il avait fait le plus dur dans cette
troisième
et là il a déjoué complètement
il avait vraiment bien joué
le début de partie
bon on est toujours moins de 2 minutes
bientôt
c'est quoi
mais la raison de prendre son temps
c'est quand même un bon pour essayer de
conclure pas laisser trop de contre le
jeu après il reste peu de temps
il veut que le pion à mettre la marche
avant
les prises
donc j'espère créer des trous dans le
Rangers
ça devient dur
er dans cette partie parce que là il a
l'avantage mais bon c'est sûr s'il
trouve pas de coup que d'un qui se prend
la pression que l'aura est faible
ça peut ça peut faire de la tremblante
sous la minute il voit rouge
le flamme rouge
avait une belle attaque de Victor l'a
fait voilà
mais il l'a fait mais il l'a fait
il avait attaqué 800 mètres
tranchante alors
une belle finale et en même temps la
dame prend une belle diagonale parce que
bon a priori Wesley à partir des
échanges j'imagine mais elle peut être
dangereuse à son tour vers le roi blanc
même très dangereuse c'était le meilleur
coin de la turbine c'était même le seul
coup pour maintenir un avantage
l'équipe évident parce qu'on va tu te
rends compte que après prise prise tu
n'en avion quoi
évidemment l'option Belfort tu peux
changer une tour pousser et voilà mais
donc c'est pas évident d'envisager
tout de suite
mais je pense qu'il a déjà vu au moment
où il a fait dame B5 avec son idée et là
elle a juste vérifier ses lignes ici ok
c'est bon très bien joué
très très bien joué
ton doigt dans le rouge
il change quand même les dames
mais après moi j'ai 8 tours à 7 à 4 tu
reprends à 4 ou C2
fini avec classe
pour faire une belle petite pause avant
mais là c'est terminé
ouais c'est qu'il y aura vraiment donné
le bâton pour se faire battre
lui-même avec son bâton
complètement
donc là on voit qu'il met quelques
échecs mais vous voyez que le pion B2
n'est pas arrêtable et il abandonne
la partie est terminée on va vous
communiquer le résultat il a fait nul
donc il s'est qualifié donc on va faire
une dernière pause avant l'Armageddon et
l'ultime partie de cette journée
merci
on revient très bientôt allez à toute
1 2
saviez-vous que vous pouvez pimenter vos
parties en ligne et vous analyses avec
des emojis il vous suffit de cliquer sur
l'icône emoji puis de sélectionner votre
emoji et de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur l'échiquier vous
pouvez choisir parmi une multitude de
notation de coûts d'animation
d'émoticônes et même vos personnalités
préférées du monde des échecs des
émoticônes et les emojis disparaîtront
au bout de quelques secondes en revanche
notations de coûts et les animations
spéciales restent sur l'échiquier
jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit effacées pour ce
faire il suffit de cliquer avec le
bouton gauche de la souris sur l'emoji
ou de cliquer sur le bouton Tout effacer
essayez tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
c'est reparti pour pour cette finale il
y a eu 7 minutes contre 15 les deux
joueurs qui ont joué à fond
on va repasser vite fait le début de la
partie
fabule
mais ça se passe plutôt bien pour les
noirs
si si les blancs trouvent du jeu allez
le roi en tout cas il a une grosse
avance à la pendule
et donc il a commencé à 8 minutes 12
Wesley
8 minutes 12
je sais pas comment il a pensé à mettre
ce 12 secondes
en tout cas il a il a vite joué dans
l'ouverture il a une position
il est quand même un tout petit peu
moins bien mais bon il est content
c'est très clair ce qu'il doit faire
ça va être plus simple de trouver les
coups
attention dans tous les sports plus
simple de défendre de garer le bus
devant tes cages de rien et
défendre et de mettre des taxes que de
faire du jeu de créer
et
comme au tennis en fait ou tu fais pas
de fautes enfin tu ramènes bon c'est sûr
courir courir courir ça te fatigue mais
c'est moi ce qui est c'est moins créatif
c'est pas facile quand même au tennis
mais bon
capable de ramener
qui est au charbon là il allait prendre
le pion à deux
[Musique]
tu vois tu te dis tu restes option H5 H6
dans la tronche ou quoi c'est un peu un
peu dangereux quoi ce qui fait
va donc
un peu dangereux parce que voilà il est
parti sans tresser dans le bas alors
elle va pas être perdue parce que c'est
l'attaquer la communication c'est pas ça
le sujet mais le sujet il est bien là
c'est ce coup de H5 il gagne un tempo
sur le cavalier qui doit repartir et
maintenant soit H6 peut-être pour mettre
une épine dans les noirs ou même
peut-être qu'il valise G5 qui est joué
qui est joué et qui fait peut-être mal
hein bon ça donc pour l'éviter il faut
faire G6 a priori il y avait une autre
option c'était cavalier F5 mais là on
voit qu'on perd le cavalier
oui peut-être
on prend des trucs à droite à gauche
maintenant en tout cas il a fait G6
mais ça fait des gros trous en tout cas
dans sa position et c'est le tour qui
est prête à venir à l'attaque
par là-bas
et peu de temps pour
il est assez vite là dessus en
négligeant un peu le danger il y a de
l'autre côté quoi il a pris tellement
peu de temps pour avoir les noirs que
finalement il était obligé de se
précipiter sur les coups
il doit penser pouvoir défendre mais un
simple plan comme à gérer d'âme des deux
f4h4
chemin un petit zigzag de la dame pour
rentrer sur la case H7 peut faire très
mal
un monsieur parce que
bon ça ressemble
franchement je vois pas s'en sortir
ça ressemble pas à grand-chose
c'est pas à quel point c'est un grand
défenseur il est très bon pour être
solide et il a un bon répertoire et tu
ne mets pas trop en danger mais une fois
que c'est fait avec c'est là
je sais pas si c'est le plus ressources
full de tous très mauvaise partie de sa
part
c'est dur
en tout cas ça joue logique et fort en
face mais lui n'hésite pas à attaquer F5
[Musique]
je crois qu'il est condamné ouais
F7 c'est terminé Fab bon il y a plus de
partir en fait non il y a pas une partie
tout simplement le temps d'ouvrir une
porte de la refermer
et c'est fini mais c'était terminé ouais
la montagne accouche d'une souris
en même temps c'est une montagne mais
bon
vraiment laissé passer le match dans la
partie précédente
il est très bien il avait pouvait
prendre l'initiative et attaquer
gratuitement il en a pas voulu par
par les échecs
je pense qu'il va abandonner très
rapidement
sur cavalier H6 je suppose non mais Adam
G8 mat ouais
couvrir Dame des 8 échecs pour ça que
j'en ai déduit qui voulait ça mais oui
maintenant
si on récapitule le tableau
il est où ce tableau il était tout en
haut hop là donc elle a été mis à jour
donc en gros on a en demi-finale
demain à de cette offre à rognan mais
sûrement qu'on s'attardera plus sur le
match entre Magnus 45 et Fabienne
ocarina et dans le nous en bracket
ok on sera déjà là
des matchs en deux parties ce qu'on fait
d'essayef et il tourida contre ventes
forest
ok surtout on verra bien sur ce merci à
tous d'avoir suivi et on se retrouve
demain à 17h pour la suite du tournoi
ciao ciao
saviez-vous que vous pouvez pimenter vos
parties en ligne et vous analyser avec
des emojis il vous suffit de cliquer sur
l'icône emoji puis de sélectionner votre
emoji et de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur l'échiquier vous
pouvez choisir parmi une multitude de
notation de coûts